joe seems cool but that tweet about
anti-racism was kind of freaky yeah i
think that
uh i think that most likely she was not
aware of the context
that surround those phrases she seems
like a normie i thought yeah
but listen it was kind of weird for me
to see the the libertarian candidate
telling
people we must do anything yeah i'm like
wait wait wait wait wait
must do something i don't care if we
must have you know uh
you know twinkies from the from the gas
station i'd be like we mustn't do
anything don't tell me what to do
i totally agree that that was that was
it for me i mean granted i think the
anti-racism stuff is
just like legit racism yeah with a
different name yeah it's clearly racist
when spencer
retweeted abram kennedy the other day
you know really
you didn't know that richard spencer so
ibrahim khan
oh yeah yeah that's not wrong right amy
barrett yeah when amy barrett
someone kennedy was criticizing amy
barrett because she adopted haitian kids
yeah and so then spencer just goes
he's not wrong and it's like amazing but
that you know
you know they like doing they like
saying well uh you know he's just
pretending so that he can
the democrats it's like what are you
talking about the dude's been completely
honest like he's comfortable with being
called the white nationalist i'm not i'm
i'm not convinced he's lying about what
he's saying now
yeah and there are a lot of people that
that i know that i'm friendly with that
uh that i'm friends with that are of the
same mind they're like oh i think it's a
you know it's he's lying he's only
saying that to help trump and blah blah
but if spencer is honest about his
white nationalist goals which i don't
see any reason to think that he's not
he definitely didn't get out of trump
what he was hoping to get out of trump
trump passed no legislation that
benefited the whites
you know so um it makes sense that he
would be well
the guy that's going to support critical
race theory
and raise racial consciousness hopefully
among white people
is joe biden so i'm going to vote for
joe biden and if you if you understand
it like that it makes sense
the guy that's going to be saying it's
okay to have critical race theory
all over the place and hopefully have
more white people being aware that
they're white and blah blah you know
it's
it's in my opinion it's a terrible thing
like that's not how you base someone's
value but
it makes sense if you're you know if
you're a racist that's like well who's
going to go ahead and
make people think about race a lot you
know you know about repealing prop 209
in california right i do i do
so this is we talk about it quite a bit
because it's probably one of the most
shocking bits of legislation we've seen
coming from the democrats it's prop 16
repeal prop 209 and it strikes the
civil rights legislation from the
california constitution pertaining to
public employment contracting and
education
so if you have donald trump who says it
is a violation of civil rights law to
tell people that certain races are
better or worse that's critical race
theory
and then you have the democrats saying
we literally want to make it legal to
discriminate based on race who do you
think the racists are going to vote for
they're not going to vote for trump
trump's saying we have a civil rights
law in this country yeah the democrats
are like
we're actively repealing those well then
all of a sudden the white nationalists
are like oh that sounds good i guess
yeah i you know and i've had again
conversations with people that i'm
friendly with and
and they either are unaware
of what the implications of repealing
that law
uh are or uh they just say oh i don't
think that that's gonna happen right
that's what i hear there's a lot of
dismissal there's a lot of people that
are
you know and i understand not
everybody's extremely online and i
i qualify as an extremely online person
fair enough
but just because everyone isn't
extremely online doesn't mean that
you know that they're wrong you know and
brushing off something isn't a good idea
you know how they like to push that
narrative of like the white supremacists
everywhere and like the evil white
supremacist militias are coming so i i
have like i've asked friends and i'll
say
which do you think is more dangerous the
far left or the far right
and of course the president oh the far
right easily and why is that because
they're nazis they're white supremacists
all that stuff i say okay so you think
there's a prominent faction of like
white supremacists
militant people going around and they're
ready to take power and they're gonna go
to war and they're fighting for trump
and all that stuff they're like oh you
know it
so don't you think that if you repealed
the law that uh
made it illegal to discriminate based on
race
these rampant white supremacist
organizations take advantage of that
and then start creating white-only
spaces they're like well
i mean i don't know i'm like well but
there's there's a bunch of these people
right they're everywhere are there's
millions of them
okay so if you appeal this law then
they're going to start forming well
it doesn't make sense no justification
for what they're doing it doesn't mean
it doesn't
and i've heard a lot of excuse making
where they're like well i think you're
looking too far into what it might be
instead of what they're trying to do
and i was like and i know what they're
trying to do they're trying
what they're publicly saying is they
want affirmative action back yeah and
i'm like okay
did affirmative action go away and
that's what that's that's what basically
you can't discriminate based on race you
can't have affirmative action okay i
didn't realize that
i thought that they were still
affirmative action laws in uh i i don't
know
to what extent they do it but what
they're arguing is that the repealing of
prop 209
it's called the affirmative action bill
repeal prop 209 and i laugh
because every every every activist
website and every voter information
database
says this bill will make it legal to
have affirmative action and i'm like
you could write this bill make it legal
to have a white only government building
it does the exact same thing but they
choose which one to highlight
instead of giving the voters the
information about what they're voting on
they cherry-pick the most
you know the one that sounds good you
could you could even say
this one helps the state get you know do
away with evil racism
sure it's an opinion it's it's framing
that's what we're gonna that's that's
what uh we're gonna get yeah i i think
it's a i think it's a
uh a bad idea um
as i've heard people make the state's
rights uh argument which i
blows my mind because i'm like you're
you're making a states right
rights argument about racism
you realize that we had a war about that
right yeah that's what the
argument that the south made was we have
the state's right
to keep people enslaved
and we fought a war and said no you
don't
yeah and now you're making that argument
again
well so blows my mind when when joe
tweeted this
she tweeted she tweeted that slogan it's
not enough to not be racist we must
actively be anti-racist
clearly she doesn't know what she's
saying the first thing is libertarian
shouldn't be saying what we must do for
one thing
but the scarier thing is that her
willingness to repeat it without knowing
what it is
is isn't it's like outside of look if
she was serious about it
the anti-racist ideology is literal
racism yeah they just put that ante in
front of it
the way i i try to describe it to people
is that racism is a spectrum
and racism and anti-racism are the exact
same thing
yeah with different with different goals
but the goals
i should say with different um what's
the right way to uh um
they're the same goals with the same
belief structure
but different emotions behind them
almost yeah i think you're right yeah
the only thing the only the only
difference
is our emotions are different it's it's
it's racism where they claim they love
you but they need to discriminate
against you for love
versus racism based on hate it's it's
it's to me it almost seems like a mom
mentality
where you're like i'm doing this for
your own good so let me just help you
you need me to make this difference for
you whereas
racism is like i'm going to tell you
what to do yeah yeah i get it
so for her to tweet it out and then
double down on it
and the libertarian party double down on
it i saw a lot of people saying they
wouldn't support the libertarians over
it because that's like freaky
i myself made a a big tweet and got into
it with some people that were
libertarians uh
got into it with uh nick sarwark who was
the lp
chair you're not a real libertarian you
know i mean that's that's the
that's how you know you're a real
libertarian when someone tells you
you're not a real engineer
do you ever see the uh the groundskeeper
willie meme yes damn
libertarians they ruined libertarianism
yeah it's true it's true
and you know so i i understand what
you're saying i got into it like i said
with with some of the
the left-leaning libertarians um and
with
star wars himself and i i don't
understand
why uh the discourse
around that was so dismissive about
people that had a problem with it
yeah um other than you know when you say
hey look
anti-racism isn't what you think it is
it's it's it's not uh i
describe anti-racism and racism uh like
matter and anti-matter yeah it's the
same thing
it's just charged differently right
that's that's kind of like what yeah
that's kind of
true what i was trying to get at yeah
it's like there's a different energy
behind it but it has the same goal the
same output
and i guess i guess the difference
between that analogy though if you took
anti-racism and written put it together
i guess
i guess you might actually get an
explosion i mean it'd be kind of good if
you could take all the racists and all
the anti-racists and put them together
and not blow up
no no i would love it because that
because that's happening a lot of
that's a lot of energy yeah yeah well so
what so what do you like about joe what
do you like about libertarians
uh i like the fact that i so i've heard
you talk about
um the i forget what it was called
this the spectrum of of caring for
compassion and and how libertarians are
just all liberty i forget what the
oh the uh the moral foundations yeah the
moral foundations and
i'm 100 on the same page with you
because my
entire world view is
i'm not looking for any particular
result
i want people to be free and that's the
that's the the what i hold you know as
sacred people should be allowed
to live their lives however they want
and
in any way that they see fit as long as
they're not harming anyone else yeah
and i think that that's the best way to
[Music]
allow people to design their life
in a way that they best see fit to
you know to affect their happiness there
are some challenges there though
for instance borders borders yeah yeah
so it's a big big libertarian argument
i was very much an open borders
kind of libertarian and then kovid
made me go yep
um because to be honest the economic
argument about borders to me makes sense
right so you really shouldn't have any
kind of
uh limitations on people going places to
work um
and i'd always i'd had i'd had a
grudging acceptance of borders because
as long as there's
some kind of uh social safety net
you can't just let anyone come into the
country and sign up for your social
safety net you have to have some kind of
control over that
because we're already 100 trillion
dollars in unfunded liabilities and
and all of the economic arguments um
but then when covet hit then i
definitely was like you know
it's probably a good idea for a country
to have
control over its borders and uh and
control over who's coming in and who's
coming out
yeah the that's the big libertarian
argument i hear a lot it's you're not a
real libertarian because
you're imaginary borders i actually got
an argument with this very like
relatively well-known libertarian who
like started threatening me
because i'm like pro-borders uh the way
to describe myself is
i would i'm left-leaning libertarian on
most things but realism makes me more
liberal because i think we need a little
bit more authority
uh not towards authoritarianism leading
towards liberty but a little bit
you need you need some kind of system in
place to maintain
these freedoms because i guess the the
the concern is looking at it from a
historical spec perspective
the places that were just open and free
to move about you get taken advantage of
by either you know manipulative forces
or physical forces
so but anyway uh specifically unto the
libertarian party though is there is
there anything joe jorgensen
like in terms of her policies that
there's nothing specific about
uh joe herself it's the libertarian
libertarian party platform is pretty
good uh
a libertarian executive who's not
looking to be
because i'm on the same page as you are
about uh foreign interventionism and
wars and stuff like that um that to me
is is a very big deal
um i'm a very pro-2a kind of guy so
gun rights and and stuff like that uh i
would love to see the atf abolished i
would love to see
a whole lot of government agencies
abolished um
the police no not the police um
fbi maybe or shrink the fbi
yeah that's that's where i i'm torn
especially because
seeing like we have a lot of problem
with the fbi like to
sort of set people up it's not
entrapment but you send in a guy who
then like starts nudging him come on
come on do it do it and they're like
okay fine
you're under arrest it's kind of like
yeah okay you're justifying yourself
that's what happened
to randy weaver at the ruby ridge thing
as they they were yeah they were trying
to get him to
you know oh we got you on your shotgun
was too short or whatever and if you
if you go and get involved with these
guys then we'll go ahead and look the
other way and it just you know
went to crap thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back
to check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time